The sauce. Kevin here with two envelopes.
One of them contains twice as much money as the other one.
And you get to choose which one you want to take.
But before you open your envelope and find out whether you've won the
smaller prize or the larger prize,
you have the opportunity to switch to the other
envelope. So.
Do you, do you switch? The answer is.
Now irrefutably 100%. No,
in our scenario it makes absolutely no statistical difference,
which envelope you choose.
Each one could contain the lower amount of money or the higher amount of money
with equal probability.
And you have zero information to help you choose one over the other
right.
Wrong. The answer is irrefutably.
100%. Yes. Switch the envelopes.
And there's a mathematical explanation for why, right?
What is happening here?
Let's look, let's,
let's start at the beginning.
The origin of the two envelopes paradox is just as confusing as the
problem itself in 1953, Belgian mathematician.
Maurice Krawczyk posed a scenario in his book about recreational mathematics,
in which two men compared the values of neckties,
their wives bought them with neither man. Knowing the prices.
Also in 1953,
a math book credits a similar puzzle using plain cards to physicist,
Erwin, Schrodinger ever hear of Schrodinger's cat,
where a cat in a box is both alive and dead until you open the box
and find out, yeah, same God. And in our problem,
the forces at play on the same, whether we're using playing cards,
neck ties or envelopes, Oh,
also I'm wearing my brand new birthday paradox shirt.
I have a floating the space,
baby bracketed by the chart detailing the probability of at least two people
sharing a birthday versus the number of people.
It's in my new Vsauce to store link below where it for all
the space children. So look,
the logic for not switching envelopes is pretty straightforward given that you
don't know anything about either one or even what the higher and lower
values are inside them.
One is just as good as the other,
but the math in favor of switch.
Ching is kind of compelling.
Let's.
Say that the envelope you choose contains X dollars.
We don't know how much X is just that something in the envelope
we can call X.
The probability of that envelope containing these smaller value is
one half. And the probability of it containing the larger amount is,
is one half is, is 50%.
The other envelope either contains twice that amount,
two X or half that amount, one half X.
If X turns out to be the higher value than the other envelope contains
one half X.
If your envelope X is the lower value than the other envelope
contains two X makes sense.
I've talked about expected value in a few other Vsauce, two videos.
It's the average of the possible outcomes of a series of probabilistic
events,
which we can use to identify the most advantageous course of action.
So to find the expected value of the envelope, we didn't choose.
We add the value of the only two possibilities weighted
by their probability
like this one over two times two X plus one over two
times, one, half X equals five,
over four X, half of the time,
the other envelope will contain two X and half of the time,
the other envelope will contain one half X,
which equals an expected value of five fourths.
X five fourths.
X is 25% more than just X.
So our best possible choice is to switch to the other envelope.
Cool. We did it, but that makes no sense.
You have a simple, clean 50,
50 chance of choosing the envelope with more money inside and
switching can't change that.
But the math just told us that it can,
don't worry though. It gets weirder.
What if I said you could switch envelopes again, if you wanted to, well,
then you just go through the same process over and over again.
Always switching, never opening forever and ever, and ever,
and ever. And Nervar, and blurber those aren't words,
but you get the point because switching makes the most mathematical sense with
switching, gaining you a 25% advantage.
And I just proved it. So
let's come back to math later. It's time for logic logician,
Raymond Smulian posts two scenarios for the paradox. First,
the risk of gaining twice,
the amount in your envelope is worthwhile when the alternative is only
losing half of it,
you're gaining X or you're only losing half of X.
The potential payoff is twice as high as your risk of loss
makes perfect sense,
but why an envelope contains X and the other contains two
X.
So you're either gaining X or losing X
also make sense, but both can't be true.
So we're gonna do this problem again, using economics, professor Barry,
nail buffs variation.
Let's say that we give an envelope to player one and then flip a coin.
If it's heads,
we put double that amount in the second envelope and give it to player
two. If it's tails,
we put half that amount in the envelope and give it to player to me.
If their player knows how much is in their envelope or the outcome
of the coin toss, once they open their envelopes in secret,
they can switch with each other. If they both agree to switch it,
play your opens their envelope and finds 10 bucks with equal
probability.
They think that switching to player two's envelope will get them 20
bucks for a $10 gain,
or take them down to five bucks for a $5 loss
player.
One decides to switch because switching gives them a greater possible
reward relative to what they might lose.
Player two who's in another room,
opens their envelope and finds five bucks.
They think there's a 50% chance that switching to player one's envelope will get
them 10 bucks for a $5 game or get them only $2 and
50 cents for a $2 and 50 cent loss.
So player two also thinks that what they stand to gain
is greater than what they might lose.
They are absolutely sure that their upside is better than their
downside,
but it's obvious that both players can't have an
advantage in this game.
That's important if you're confused at this point,
good Martin Gardner, one of history's greatest puzzle solvers and care docs.
Explainers knew the answer, but admitted that there just,
wasn't a simple way to communicate Kate,
the flaw in mathematical reasoning and sadly
that's where our journey ends. No,
it's not because we can figure this out.
Think of it this way.
The total sum of money in the envelopes is three
units,
a small unit and a larger value that's made up of two
smalls that combine to form a total of X.
If you've got these smaller envelope,
it's value is X over three.
And if you have the larger envelope,
it's value is two X over three.
When you switch from small to large, you gain X over three.
And when you switch from large to small, you lose X over three.
So the expected value of switching is one half
times, two X minus X,
over three plus one half times X minus two
X over three,
which equals
zero. There's just no value in switching. It doesn't help us.
And it doesn't hurt us,
which is probably what you knew on till we got math involves
the two envelopes problem is a lot more than just X
and two X,
which is what makes it a false cynical paradox,
because there appears to be a gain from switching.
When we fail to consider that the States of the two envelopes,
don't actually reflect simple values of X and two X,
a two X envelope is only two X when it's the larger
amount.
And the one half X envelope is only one half X when
it's the smaller amount, without recognizing that difference.
Basic algebra playing off our common sense,
fools us into thinking that each switch do gives you a gain of
five over four or 25%.
It's really a matter of perspective,
depending on which envelope, your holding,
which one you think you have, which one you think you don't have.
And which one you want to wind up with your course of action might
be incredibly clear or not.
And then clear again.
And then not again until you realize that
no matter if you diagnose it mathematically,
no matter if you deconstruct it logically,
no matter what you do when it comes to the two envelope
paradox, you were right all along
and as always,
thanks for watching
[inaudible] Hey,
I actually started developing this video and began shooting it when
brilliant.org came to me about sponsoring it. I really.
Like working with brilliant because it's an entire platform based on learning
math and science, by playing with them,
something you may have noticed,
I'm kind of a fan of and surprise, surprise.
They have a really good explanation of these perplexing probability
scenarios.
They're interactive puzzles help you expose misconceptions and you are
learning by playing.
This is just one of 60 plus courses on brilliant that teach you by
walking you through puzzles and guiding you and figuring out the solutions,
basically teaching you how to think,
which I would highly recommend.
So head over to brilliant.org/vsauce two,
sign up for free in the first 200 people get 20% off
an annual premium subscription. So don't check it out.
It's awesome. Okay. Bye.